when i finished high school
and i was 18 years old actually about 18
and a half i joined the u.s army
and i enlisted to become what's called a
combat engineer the designation for that
was 12
bravo 12b and combat engineers
do infantry stuff but they also handle
demolition
and minefields and obstacles and and you
know
drive heavy equipment and i thought well
that's for me and
so i got sent to fort leonard wood which
is where they they train the engineers
and unlike many of the other
types of of uh mosses that's military
occupational specialty that you might
have where you go to basic training
first and do that and get completely
finished with that
and then go on to do your your advanced
training your ait
with the combat engineers it was
combined
into this roughly 13-week period
they did have a kind of ceremony for us
it was it was pretty short
there was a bigger one at the end but
they had something to to designate that
we'd like made it through the basic
part of it although we were already
doing a lot of engineer stuff
in basic training and i'll probably talk
some other time
about all the different things that were
involved in basic training
what i want to talk about here is what
happened
when we finished up which is they gave
us a three day
leave which means that we got to go off
post and
fort leonard wood they often call it
fort lost in the woods because it's
really in the middle of nowhere in in
missouri
and as a matter of fact when i first got
there i thought it was you know
a crazy place because i came down
from wisconsin in the middle of february
it's pretty cold here in wisconsin in
february in snowy
and it was worse way way worse in fort
leonard wood
again i'll tell you the story about that
later on
so by the time that we had finished up
with the basic training part
it was you know somewhere in april and
it it had gotten pretty nice out and
what we all did in our company was
we got a bus and i think some of the
older guys must have you know figured
this out
and we rode this bus there i think maybe
there were two buses because you know
about 120 guys and we went to this town
called lebanon
missouri and there there was a holiday
inn and we just like
rented out a whole bunch of hotel rooms
and there wasn't an awful lot to do
in lebanon missouri there's not an awful
lot there as far as i remember
although who knows it may have changed
by now this is uh
30 years ago and so you know we're
enjoying
not having to wake up on time and do all
the sort of stuff that you have to do
during basic training and
not having drill instructors yelling at
you and we wanted to have a good time
there were a few guys who actually hired
prostitutes
but i wasn't you know not only was i not
into that
i wasn't going to use the little bit of
money that i had for anything like that
but we all did want to drink and you
know i was 18 years old
so obviously in most states including my
home state of wisconsin
i couldn't legally purchase alcohol but
you know we already had a track record
of like going into milwaukee
and finding liquor stores where people
were you know not going to card you
and buying it or you'd find some older
guy to buy you stuff
and at that point in time i didn't
really have a very good sense about
what was worth buying and what was not
worth buying
you know it was sort of in the
experimental stage you might say
of of hard drinking and so that led to a
lot of you know getting sick
and buying really terrible tasting stuff
and forcing it down somehow and mixing
drinks that weren't really any good
but i knew i was probably going to want
to do two things one was like
eat food that i couldn't get on on post
and enjoy that and then the other thing
was you know get some get some liquor
so i asked you know some of the other
guys well where do you go
to get get some some liquor and they
said well there's this like
liquor shack down the road you just
gotta walk down there
it's about half a mile and you'll you'll
see it's right along the side of the
road and i was like you got to be
kidding me a shack
and they're like yeah yeah that's that's
that's what's here so you know i get
dressed and and start walking and
um go in and i think i was i was wearing
like civilian clothes
uh because we had some along with us at
the time
so i uh i go into the place and it
literally is just a shack
honest to god like you could have blown
real hard and
the walls probably would have come off
and there was like you know there were
shelves and there was like liquor
lined up along it with price tags on it
and you know there's an old uh almost
antique
cash register and then an old guy just
kind of looking at me as i'm walking in
and he's like what do you want to get
and i was like i think i'll have some
vodka and so you know he's well there
you go there's the vodkas
and i i picked one of the cheapest ones
if i remember right it was like
fleischmann's vodka
and he's like anything else and i was
like no i'm you know
this is enough for me so i paid and i
think i paid like you know five bucks
for it or something like that and i was
like well this is a really good deal
so i walk out and i've got it in you
know the proverbial brown paper bag
that people have for liquor and i'm
walking along on the way
along the highway essentially state
highway
and i get to the parking lot of the
holiday inn
and there's an old guy another old guy
and he stops me
and i'm like oh crap i bet i'm gonna get
in trouble
for being underage and and having this
this alcohol with me
and he he looks at me and this guy was
really quite old he was probably
you know in his 70s looks like he had a
quite a hard life
and from the moment he started talking i
could tell
that he was an immigrant and
he was from germany so he starts talking
and he's like so are you a soldier
and i said yeah yeah i am and he said
well what unit are you
with and i don't even remember exactly
what unit we were at the time
and he starts asking me questions about
that and i'm i'm getting kind of
nervous because i'm like maybe this guy
is going to like
call the cops on me or get in trouble
and then
suddenly he you know he looks at me and
he's like do you
do you have some some liquor there and i
was like he's like yeah i like you know
i like to drink sometimes and so i was
like well you know
do you want to have some he's like sure
you know so you get the
vodka out he takes a swig and then he
starts telling me a story and so this is
going to be a story
within a story i can't say whether it's
completely true or not because
i only have his say so about it i don't
have any reason to think that he was
actually
lying about it because it's it's quite
an incredible story and it's
it's a strange one to tell the people
that you don't really know
if it if it didn't have some at least
grain of truth to it
so this guy was an immigrant and he had
come
to the united states after the second
world war
when he was a german soldier himself and
he was quite young he was probably you
know about
my age when he got essentially drafted
conscripted it'd be the better way to
say it and you know they would just go
into places and say
you're in the army now and it was you
know like 1943
when when he got in and that was a
pretty bad
time to be in because you know this is
after the the glorious
conquests of you know taking over norway
or
you know poland or fighting france and
beating them
this was like a slog you know by that
time
belonging to the german army meant that
you were like in
you know western europe and you were
waiting for the allies to invade
or you were in italy and fighting the
allies there
or even worse the eastern front
with russia which is where the bulk of
the german military
was from 1941 onward from the
the beginning of operation barbarossa
and things had not been going well
for the germans by that time of the war
as a matter of fact
you know they were in strategic retreat
in in many places
and the russians were overwhelming them
with not just
numbers but just sheer protect
production
and um they were you know the german war
machine was was slowly grinding to
uh what would eventually be its demise
so this guy gets constrict conscripted
goes through
the brief training that he gets gets
sent out to the
eastern front and within like
a week or so he's captured he and his
whole
whole company actually his whole
battalion captured and they're all
prisoners of war
now to be a prisoner of war in
russia was not like being a prisoner of
war
uh behind say allied lines
or even unless you were like in one of
the nationalities that the germans
treated horribly
being in a german prisoner of war camp
the russian prisoners of war camps
i mean they really had nothing and so
deprivation was sort of the the you know
name of the game and
you also have all these russians who
themselves are just like 18 year old
kids as well
except for their officers and they're
ticked off at you for invading their
country
so things look pretty grim for him but
from what he said he noticed that there
really wasn't
much interest in in you know
guarding the the german prisoners
because i guess they figured well you're
out in the middle of nowhere
and they were literally out in the
middle of nowhere behind
russian lines and you know where are you
gonna go
if you escape what's gonna happen you
don't you don't speak the language
you don't know the terrain there's
there's nowhere literally to go and then
you know of course there'd be russian
winter coming
well this guy according to his story
he actually did decide to escape and
when he escaped
he found that it wasn't that difficult
to get out
what was difficult was figuring out what
to do next
and fortunately he wasn't like way up in
the north or anything he was you know
fairly far south so the weather wasn't
too bad
and he and a buddy escaped
and they would you know travel at night
and
you know there were all sorts of
interesting things that came about i
mean
one of these things what do you do for
food well they they figured out pretty
pretty quickly that
they you know they could like dig for
potatoes and
things like that and so they you know
every once in a while they'd also steal
food from places that was a bit more
dangerous i mean stealing the potatoes
was stealing too but you know you're out
in a field that nobody's looking for for
you
and they would travel mostly by night
and then they would sleep they would get
into haystacks and hide inside there
and sleep during the day and then begin
again at a twilight
another one of the big problems was your
shoes wear out
and they tried all sorts of different
remedies
the biggest thing was your souls you
know they had german boots
which were according to him not
particularly well made you know they're
for the military
and uh you know they walked along until
their boots eventually
fell apart and then they would try to
find whatever they can but he did
according to him quite a bit of walking
with with bare feet
and you know they might cover 10 miles a
day
and he walked for over an entire
year according to this guy again i i
don't have any reason to doubt him
he seemed pretty earnest and pretty
honest about this
he walked for a year and and it was
continually going
west because he knew that you know
that was the way back home and
by you know by the time that he was
actually getting closer and closer to
the russian lines
and actually closer to germany it was
pretty clear from what he could tell
that the russians had advanced quite a
ways and the germans were getting their
butts kicked
and he was like you know
i don't want to be behind german lines
or behind russian lines
when the war ends so he made it into
germany and then he could talk with
german people and he's like
and you know looking where the russians
are what the hell happened here
germany's been
devastated and they're like well you
know the americans and the british and
the french are over that way
just keep on going and they gave him you
know new boots and
a little bit of food and whatever
whatever he he could have
and by now his his friend that he
escaped with her
his fellow soldier he was out of the
picture
and he just kept going and he found a
way to get
through the russian lines
and over to where the germans were and
the germans
at that point and i don't remember what
he what he told me he he did actually
tell me like what city it was near but i
don't remember
um they they were like well you you
really
you know the americans are here we gotta
surrender to them you know forget this
russian nonsense
we gotta get over there so everybody was
moving west
you know and the german lines were just
crumbling so he did that
and he went and he found an american you
know the quickest he could
and put his hands up and you know said
you know that he was surrendering
and at first they were like who the hell
is this guy i mean he still had a little
bit of his uniform left
but he definitely was not in any any
unit or anything like that
and he had a hard time at first until
they got a translator
getting them to understand that he
wanted to surrender to be with the with
the americans
and then everything was cool after that
he was like you know i had three square
meals a day
i didn't have to walk anymore and then
after the war
ended he found a way to get to the
united states and he wound up somehow
in lebanon missouri and working for this
hotel
that we were staying in as a caretaker
and
chatting up uh somebody who he
recognized some sort of
you know common experience with of being
a
soldier and interestingly enough almost
his entire time as a soldier
he was either a prisoner of war or an
escapee right
but he probably had at least as much
time in
as i had because he at least went
through training and so
you know we chatted there and then you
know i had a few more
sips of vodka together and then he was
like oh i got to get going
very nice to to talk with you and and
meet with you and i went up to
my room where i was staying with another
guy you know
sharing the cost and that was the end of
it i never saw him after that
and we went back to fort leonard wood
and resumed our
ait training and then graduated but i've
always remembered that guy
and that story and you know
again i i don't know whether all of it's
true or not
um but i have no reason to think that it
wasn't true
and it was nice to sort of share a
moment with somebody who at that time
would have been
you know 50 years older than me who
saw something in common
so that's that's the whole story within
a story
of the german escapee
from the pow camps that i met in lebanon
missouri
you